ok well I come to this video super night
AJ yep dojo play this kind of this
philidor neo Philidor is play this very
aggressively I don't really know how you
play that as black to be honest I hope
this is possible I'm really inventing
things on the go here okay you can take
twice right Lettie 6 it's not doing that
not sure why ok this shouldn't be too
bad right it looks kind of active pawn
takes Knight b6
might be one of those cases where oh I
can't play C 5c form not sure if it is a
good idea but it it's an interesting one
getting this night out of play but ok
that's just plain ol move in this
position the move f4 is not really
helping white a lot it is mostly
weakening now but it's still obviously
super easy so he can put out everything
in a second yeah I know it's a
complicated position i think you know
interesting
I mean I have a very decent development
so it shouldn't shouldn't be bad for
black I would be quite surprised if
white is better here but you never know
there's some kind of know kind of tactic
I didn't see it ok now he is playing
some some consolidating moves let's say
he is kind of weak on them on the in the
center here maybe I can at the right
moment jump in but at the moment it
would just open up is this diagonal and
so on ok so it gives up the bishop pair
then possibly I know what he wants to do
before yeah ok well I'm obviously there
is satisfied here the bishop won't be
seven is not nice but what you see of
doing Queen g4 I've Queen g6 yeah Queen
g6 and stuff is hanging the rook is
hanging and the queen is hanging
hmm
and yes take care of this annoyed white
reason yo he's just losing big stuff
here peace I think yeah Queen g-force
one of those super quick moves that
really really don't work what can you do
yeah but the position was already kind
of kind of difficult I think whenever
you have this situation with f4 played
and the move f4 is really accomplishing
nothing it's mostly weakening and yeah
I'm pretty okay with black maybe not not
better or anything but I should be okay
this is accelerating the development
quite a bit and yeah c3 it was okay and
yeah I'm just better developed he's got
this Bishop back on c1 and this III is
weak if I swig and so on and we are
taking on d5 if you have to do that this
is kind of trauma from capitulation
maybe you have to go before check simply
say okay let's play this this position
yeah this is this is probably something
that white can draw with some suffering
suffering because my bishop will
actually enter the position while his
bishop is passive but its opposite
colors bishops you know very very good
God huge drawing tendencies yeah and
here was quicken making sure that before
it's not coming T it's difficult he
cannot move the bishop and I threaten
this Bishop a6 threaten her as a
playlist to get them get more active and
T I was expecting a rookie move rookie
one and maybe trading check check maybe
may putting this out unless I don't want
to blunder stuff but this
oops sorry here would be fantastic no
yeah it was a nice position but Queen
Queen g4 is some it's leading to to a
big problem Queen hangs Luke hangs and
if he takes again two pieces are hanging
so it's losing one of them unavoidable
okay thanks for watching